yeah this is kind of random video
backstory I guess I was just chillin at
home and I was like yo what should I do
so I hooked up rollercoaster can three
but I was like no I'm not gonna really
work in any of my projects and an idea
that I have then I have had for a very
long time is to try pixel art in
molecules like in three I mean all the
cool kids doing in my crafts and things
like that these days and I do like the
idea of doing pixel arts so I figured
this might be possible with path covers
and stuff like that so I just wanted to
try that so open up the game tried it
was recording the entire way through and
in the end I felt like yeah this is
something you can do in Mullica stick in
three it actually does work pretty well
and it's arguably faster and easier than
minecraft pixel art because you know in
my quality have to move around and
you're limited to the directions of one
avatar where in veliko ii 3 you can just
freely roam around with the advanced
camera and it's pretty easy to use
the only restriction that there is is
there are barely any colors in this game
that you can actually use especially for
kids skin tones or certain shades of
colors but overall I think this really
worked pretty well so yeah you'll just
see in the end when I made but I'm
currently using which set is this again
yeah Brian to sparta covers you can
honestly use anything for this but i
wanted to use the satin because it has a
very simple texture it doesn't really
have too much going on and i felt like
it was the most neutral and close to
moby steel jungle colors as i could get
with path cover sets so that's why i use
this one and started from the bottom now
we're here know started from the bottom
because that's you know just generally
easier you know where you have to start
and where you're eventually going to end
although I didn't because as you could
just see I had to move the I had to copy
this thing and place it again because it
kind of look or kind of looked awkward
because you know it was too close to the
park border which is actually something
that I did notice I figured beforehand
that I could get away with doing loads
of sprites on one park map because these
things in sandbox are pretty big and you
know I'm doing this on 1/4 tile so every
pixel on here is a quarter tile but in
the end that actually meant that the
was going to be huge and it didn't fit
within the poke borders at the point
that I started it so now the feet are
very close to the pike border underneath
this thing here so that's what's going
on here
and currently just working on them legs
you know and get that get that thing
going
that beautiful sprite over there and
this is a bit over not really going to
call it lewd but probably not the best
sprite that I could have come up with i
wouldn't destroy ledee on first the
Pokemon lady on but yeah you know that's
one of my favorite Pokemon but it's just
kind of small you know it's not really
much of a challenge
it's just a small bug and really
honestly if you're going to try and make
sprites why would you start off with a
bug it's probably going to be my second
thing if I have to do this again
really this is just something I wanted
to try and kind of just want the show to
to show that this is possible and it's
actually quite fun to do this like I can
see why people do this in a micron maps
but I can really like doing this in mala
Costa kanthri as well was actually
surprisingly fun to do this it's not
that creative you know you're not really
coming up with your own things you're
just practically copying an image except
in pixelated version of it but it's so
it's still really fun to do this in
Monaco second three and definitely not
hard I think pretty much anything anyone
can do this and that's also part of the
fun but I'm not going to make this into
a series though if there is great demand
and I feel like doing it possibly but
now I'm not going to do that that just
no roller coaster go through I need to
focus on my pikes and my coasters this
is just something that I felt like doing
also yes there was some underboob action
in this in this image I just couldn't I
couldn't ignore that I even made this
image less nude than it already was
because the outfit was actually in the
original picture even more yeah like
this but you know what is it's it's
pixelated it's roller coaster and three
and I felt like yo Rio : let's roll with
this because this is cool
this is if I want to start off with
something you're gonna start off with a
badass character not a freaking boat
Pokemon who does the anyway so [ __ ]
Sony Vegas is buggin right now so let me
this clip you yeah and I'm back and Sony
Vegas is also working so that's really
amazing now you as you may notice yeah
there definitely are some problems with
the colors and it's not it's all my side
too like Game Boy Color ish where you
would always have these weird sprites
that kind of looked a bit weird because
there is no lighter skin tone I mean
that that kind of red brown ish color
works pretty well actually for the skin
but the thing is that only really works
for the shadowy skin and you always have
these lighter shades of skin that you
want to show as well but there is no
column for that so those things are just
white for the time being if there are
any path covers that have a lighter
texture I really want to make that you
know I could do that but effort don't
want to put too much effort into this
seriously this is this is something
small
this was the complicated part of the
sprites because knowing this character
she is like the weirdest streaking
outfit ever and it has like weird stuff
on top of it and it's very complicated
and I was like ah while I was trying to
make this thing because you know it's
confusing alright all these sprites all
these pixels I mean and if they're all
over the place but it works out in the
end so that's awesome and it is a pretty
cool sprite I do have to say for this
many pixels you know some images just
don't work out as pixelated images but I
guess this one does no I I always have
this this thing with anime that the
things that make anime anime always
disappear when you make it when you're
making them into sprites like they're
the big stupid weeaboo eyes always
disappear him and the general style of
it being draw is it's kind of gone but
otherwise it's pretty damn awesome and
faces are always hard in pixelated
versions because you're either gonna
have one eye that's smaller than the
other one and one eye that's yeah what
one the other way is going to be bigger
automatically whatever you're talking
about noses always look awkward I think
this face really does work so that's
also an advantage and yes I know that
the left eye slightly smaller than the
right eye over here but you know the
thing is the right eyes like underneath
the hair over here which would skip I
mean skipped damnit
which I'm sorry about but I couldn't I
perhaps.perhaps thought it stuff I mean
no okay perhaps stopped recording
because you know there wasn't any room
left on my PC but yeah here you see the
full sprite it's pretty damn awesome I
do like it it's a really amazing sprite
and I mean yeah it's an awesome image to
start with next to the path entrance
over here so you can actually see how
incredibly massive it is and here it's
next to a birch tree so yeah why I
broach because the trees are awesome and
it really does show the sheer size of
these things
so is this going to be something you can
use in your parks most likely not it's
definitely not that useful in the in the
general wallah cosec and three stuff but
I do like working in this stuff so I
might I might make some more of this but
this has been pretty awesome today thank
you for watching this stupid random
video and I'll see you all next time in
which I'll do something serious again
hopefully probably